[Music]
okay so remember that show that we
watched the trailer for MILF Manor
yeah you've been binging well yeah it
came out
first episode or maybe three episodes I
don't know but I watched the first
episode because I'm doing a video on it
and uh
so people will see these jokes in my
video if they watch that but I I do have
to tell you about it because it is it
truly is one of the most insane dating
shows but it also just shows I've ever
watched
you should watch it if you like if you
you know if you have time between
Starcraft matches you should try and
turn it on
yeah I don't know I might have to factor
it in but try and see if you can slot it
in somewhere in your day
uh okay okay well maybe when you get
back or something uh maybe I did just
order a mechanical keyboard to the next
venue did you actually
yeah
absurd you should just put that on your
Rider
mechanical keyboard new one every event
yes yes
hi I'm gonna need a [__] Alienware PC
at a brand new one yeah that's what you
should at every video yeah all right
okay so anyway let me tell you about it
so we watched the trailer for remember
yeah and like that it ends with like
that you know sort of like oh who like
the this the reveal of the guys right
and we were like were they the children
they were obviously they're the sons
obviously right
oh my God so immediately like you know
how TLC kind of has that like weird sort
of like half reality Vibe where yeah
like on the reveal
it was very clearly like the director
was like okay stop we're gonna get
singles of each of you just react do
like 10 reactions for us and say what
the heck that's my mom phrases like that
just like we'll do a series like just
run through them right now action you
know so the reactions are like
mom
like what is my mom doing here what the
heck
mommy who put my hot ass Mommy here is
that my MILF what the heck
so okay so one of the ladies it's like
10 you know pretty normal I would say
normal-ish moms and then there's this
one that is like 50 years old a lot of
work done blonde Orange County I
remember right her name is Disco Mommy
that's what she calls herself because
she's really into house music sorry
that's her persona for when she's
listening to house music and in party
mode it's disco Mommy
right cool her son is 20.
20 years old
like this dude and and the most 20 year
old guy ever like
uh I don't even know how to explain it
you know like when you're joking about
love Island
there being like a you know like a
skateboard kid on there 16 year old yeah
it's like not even dating at all he's
just like there to like skate he's like
that he's like the real life
personification of that like just should
not be on this show at all probably has
never even had a girlfriend oh my god
dude and his mom is that is that is the
crazy one right
so the crazy one
immediately is like trying to [__] every
single guy there on night one
and at one point it's her her son and
this dude that she's kind of macking on
chilling at the bar together with
another one of the MILFs that MILF
leaves and goes to bed so then it's just
the three of them right so she's kind of
flirting on this guy and the guy is kind
of like oh this kid that's like kind of
near my age I'm supposed to be friends
with this guy and this is his mom he's
kind of trying to like be the sort of
mediator here and like not trying to be
too forward or whatever and she there's
this moment where she puts her arm
around him and she goes this is your dad
she looks her son in the face
and says this is your dad
and the this kid just has this look
on his face that's like
we're watching trauma happen in real
time
what are what a what a good show like
I've never and I I was sitting there
just dropped my jawed [__] dropped
and he it's you know he's so crazy
because you see him go into this like
defense mechanism mode where clearly his
brain chemistry is like is like altered
and he's like kind of used to this sort
of thing because he's like oh Mom knock
it off come on he's got there's like
three phrases that he just repeats over
and over again because it's like he's in
this mode where it's like oh okay put
put your guard like deal with this
trauma
I I've never and then she tries to bring
so the one of the catches about the show
is that the mom and the son the moms and
the sons are staying in the same room
together
yeah and they do that on purpose so that
if a mom tries to bring back one one of
the other dudes she has to try to get
her son out of the room like and she
tries to do that she tries to bring him
back to the room and he's like come on
Mom I want to sleep I want to go to
sleep I'm [__] blocking you Mom and the
mom's like my son is such a [__] block
like to the talking head camera
and the whole dude I'm like I feel bad
watching this I'm like I feel like this
the like shame on you to the producers
yeah this [__] show it is Twisted
it's [__] twisted
shame on you shame on you
no that that is that is [__]
this is your dad
um
you know what he has to do what
he has to [__] her mom
his mom's mom
yeah I guess the [__] is Grandma
then he looks at her and says no
this is your dad
like this is your dad I
said no he has to [__] his dad
yeah
and his grandma
see that's a thing so at one moment
they're in like the diary room together
right like they're doing their talking
head together the mom and the son and
there's this challenge the first
challenge that they do
to decide who gets the rooms with the
hot tub in it because you if you're
staying with your mom you definitely
want a room with a hot tub right
yeah and in order to uh win this this is
this is actually I think the scene right
here they like the challenge is all the
guys yeah so yeah basically looks like a
college junior does he not
yeah like it's [__] I mean even his
hair his even his haircut is just like
nah I don't know who I am yeah dude it's
so the challenge is all the guys stand
shirtless
and the moms have to go out blindfolded
and figure out which one is their son by
feeling them up right
which is I know which is [__] up in
like just in like right off the bat
that's [__] up right and then they're
in this you know they're doing the
talking head and the son goes mom just
keep like make sure when you're like
filling up these guys you keep it above
the belt okay and she's like and I'm
like yo these these incest jokes are
going crazy
you look so hard thinking about this mom
make sure you don't jack me off by
accident when you're jacking the other
guys off because that would be horrible
mom if you jacked me off shitty don't
jack me off mom
mom don't pickpocket me
that that's so dark man it's really dark
and the whole thing is
you know they play it off like it's you
know this kind of quirky sort of weird
TLC show
that's not not it's really really dark
it's like
traumatic you know you've seen Desperate
Housewives
you may remember the bachelor well the
creators of both have brought you
something really exciting it's incest
the fun way yeah
my incest life
watch 10 guys explore their Oedipus
Complex
Maybe
that's wild man yeah so I would say
definitely watch that show
and then and then the mom so then the
mom the next day she starts macking on
this other son right and she at one
point I get the First episodes Ends by
her putting her arm around the guy and
looking at the guy's mom and saying I'm
in the fantasy suite tonight like I'm
gonna [__] your son basically to her
face another one of the moms is dating
you know one of the dudes they go on a
date together and at one point they're
on a paddle board in the in the ocean
and she puts him up on her feet like
he's like doing the airplane you know on
his stomach on her feet right and I'm
like dude like
I'm like you do that with children
you know what I mean that's like a thing
you do with your kids and then it cuts
to her in the diary room she goes it was
really fun I used to do that with my son
when he was like five
I'm like this is so all types of [__]
up yeah the best part of taking down a
MILF is when she puts you in the air
like an airplane yeah man she feeds you
applesauce too
I love that [__] she gave me are you a
cougar hunter or do you just want to
bang your mom yeah